buffett's cash pal tops record with
149.2 billion dollars on hand this is
the bloomberg story
uh uh he's never had this kind of money
in cash uh surpassing a record set in
early 2020 the fresh high came even
after buffett ports more money into
buying back its own stock at 7.6 billion
dollars of repurchases in that period
the third highest tally
since the board changes policy to
buybacks in 2018 buffett has struggled
with a high class problem of having too
much money in berkshire's pockets and
not enough chances to put that to work
in higher returns as returning assets
with no major deal in recent quarters
berkshire hathaway ceo has currently
frequently turned to buybacks as one way
to deploy the cash uh uh the uh
cash how do you pronounce that word adam
d-e-l-u-g-e deluge but even with the
heightened level of buybacks during the
third quarter
wasn't enough to keep berkshire's
coffers from swelling so there's there's
criticism from both sides right now
because there's one side that's saying
you know the whole thing uh when you buy
mutual funds they said if you would have
missed the last 40 best days uh market
days instead of having a 12.8 percent
return you would have been at 6.8 right
okay if you would have missed the top 20
and then they keep giving you these
numbers if you listen if you missed the
five best days of trading you would your
returns are from 12 to eight he missed a
lot of good days especially yeah with
kovacs he missed a lot of good days a
lot of money was made every time these
guys printed money he lost a lot of
money okay
uh there's a lot of people again we've
talked about this before that's not the
first time we're talking about this
people are that are saying buffett is
losing his touch
uh he is no longer connected with what's
going on today with crypto ethereum
bitcoin
ai technology software the direction
things are going but at the same time
you can never underestimate a buffet
this guy's been around for a long long
time he's not been around for 10 years
not 20 years not 30 years this guy's
been doing this for 60 plus years nearly
70 years he's been doing this okay so
does he know something the rest of the
population doesn't know is he expecting
there to be a massive drop-off for him
to go out there and buy things for sale
i don't know why would you sit on cash
for this long and your name is warren
buffett there's got to be a reason
behind it so speculation is he expecting
a you know a major drop-off we'll see
what's going to happen adam so
how much of this has to do with
stimulus being printed you did a you did
a post the other day about how the money
will flow to the top it always does
and you know because poor people they
just pay their rent or maybe they pay
their bills now they don't know what to
do with the money so they just spend it
so the money flows to the top i know you
have strong feelings on this so
i guess what's you
why so how did he acquire
you're saying that he's been on the
sidelines this entire he's been on the
sidelines for quite a while meaning he
hasn't been he i know he he was he
shorted the he sold his air airline
stock he tended 10 9 he owned the top
four airlines he sold it all if he would
have stayed there that cost him a lot of
money yeah because it 10x when he sold
it at the bottom it's 10x since then
since but he's just been in cash this
entire time in cash and you know cash is
accumulating but he's just been in cash
so why would you be in cash and by the
way you know the whole thing when cash's
king cash is not kink okay when you're
broke and you have no money cash is king
of course when you're worth 100 billion
dollars cash is not king that money's
got to work for you so that cash has not
worked the last 12 months right
inflation
mathematically mathematically the more
you print money mathematically
everything flows to the top it flows to
you so
what he's doing
the only the only conclusion i have you
know on why he would do such a thing
is
he fully believes something catastrophic
is about to happen to the market i also
think there's one other aspect to that i
think that he has he's such an
old-school investor yeah and the way he
does value investing and doesn't buy
anything that's overpriced it's like he
like kind of like you were saying with
when you were trying to negotiate on a
house in today's market you can you
simply can't because there's like it's
so chaotic so for him it's like instead
of negotiating i'm going to wait until
it's undervalued or i can get at a good
price and that opportunity just hasn't
been around so i think between the
what's going on with the economy is such
an anomaly in terms of it's just with
printing the money and like it's so
insane how it dive dove and then went
straight back up again i think that for
him he is more on trends and what's in
the past and these trends don't match
the past and therefore he's he's not a
gambler so he's going to take a step
back i mean he did close his uh his
first investment company during a time
of turbulence where he was like he
basically told the shareholders
i'm giving you back your money you've
received a x amount of return and for me
i don't understand the market and i
don't want to do i don't want to gamble
so yeah here's your money and then he
started back up again a couple years
later when it was more kind of returned
to normalcy i think there's an there's
an aspect of that too where he's playing
and investing in what he knows and the
market that's currently going on he
simply doesn't know so what i'd like to
see in a situation like this is where he
then
has some of the younger people there who
are in the crypto market who under kind
of are learning and understanding nfts
and giving them a certain
number of the the billions of dollars
and like here here's 10 billion here's
100 billion go play ball go go do
something see what you can make with
this as opposed to just sitting on the
cash and just waiting for it uh
to catch up or let inflation catch up
i think you bring up a good point with
the value investing that's been his
entire you know mo his entire
career is that he's going to sit and
wait and wait for the right opportunity
he's not eager to just pump money into
the market for the sake of saying hey
i'm investing so that's the whole
concept of what he's doing he's kind of
almost like an old-school tiger that
just sits there and waits to pounce
something that i think warren buffett
and i'm not here to critique warren
buffett at all
but something that i i think he's
probably doing low-key but for whatever
reason it's not in the in the tabloids
or the headlines is he does need to
empower some younger people
to manifest what exactly berkshire is
going to look like
when charlie monger who's probably like
125 years old at this point
and warren buffett who's in his mid-90s
i would assume we're no longer here
calling the shots there's gonna need to
be some you know whether they're when i
say younger people can be talking about
people in their 60s they're going to
start taking on a little bit more
risk and putting this capital to work
but that is uh
the other thing is the other thing
that's interesting is that like 90 of
his wealth was made in like 10
investments
coca-cola apple
yeah so so for him it's it's nothing new
that he has
long periods of doing nothing and then
short spurts of doing a lot of buys and
stuff like that look the difference
between the world he's in and an athlete
an athlete eventually father time comes
and you say i can no longer kick it with
these young guys right
is there father time as a investor is
there father time for that i don't know
about that i don't know the beauty is
dementia is the only thing right what is
father time when you come it comes down
to the goat of investing if you think
about it
so you know
he he is known when you're at that level
you are known to trust your gut instinct
but stuff is changing so quickly today
it's not like it's changing if you were
to look at what's changing quickly in
the history of mankind after the
announcement that zuck made last week
everybody's panicking about how quickly
things are going to change how quickly
things are going to go so but i want to
show you this article can you go to my
twitter account please uh so
just yesterday msnbc at around 318
tweets out in a tweet and they change it
immediately they deleted it after the
amount of hate they got they took it
down and they change it go down a little
bit further down go go you'll see it
you'll see it keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going
uh
wait did they take you down okay go to
my facebook account
um
i don't think they took it down maybe go
to my facebook profile
uh i'll try to send this picture over to
you if you
let me see this here okay matter of fact
let me just send it to you in a way for
you you can you can air drop it to the
computer which which computer is it uh
macbook pro
macbook here see which one you want to
air drop it to just go to not this one
here we'll form we'll find it here for
you just air drop it to his computer
you want to just text it to him anyways
yesterday msnbc comes out with a story
are you doing that or no yeah i'm trying
to say it comes out with a story saying
the fact that uh uh okay this is the
article keep this article they changed
it to this
are you able to get it two more no i
don't think so
uh uh uh uh tyler i'm gonna email it to
you how about this okay because this
this is not gonna make sense if i don't
email it to you and the audience doesn't
see this send it to uh info info
valuetainment
okay
so
this is this is the ultimate gas
lighting type of stuff
um
okay it's sent let me know when you have
it
okay let me know when you have it if you
go to your email
okay click on that open it up
open it up see if you can click on it
for it to open up like for people to see
it
why the inflation we're seeing now is a
good thing that's the title
just open it up just click on it to
no what i'm trying to tell you is click
on it for it to be an image
you'll click on it twice it's not doing
anything okay let me just read it then
let me just read it then
this is go down to show what time this
was go down to show okay 3 18
november 8th yesterday the article says
the following uh the the tweet
go a little higher so they can see the
logo at the top with msnbc msnbc tweets
out why the inflation we're seeing now
is a good thing
okay now you tell me how to help that
makes any sense
why the inflation we're seeing now is a
good thing so don't worry about the
american people it's okay that we're
having inflation
they immediately change the title they
delete this tweet this tweet is deleted
go to the top go to the article that i
sent you would you screenshot it
yeah of course i did so they said how
kovitt became the unlikely hero of our
inflation crisis the case we're not
panic not painting the inflation we're
seeing now as mystery mysterious
disastrous affliction that's descended
on the economy go a little lower for us
to read the article in regards to
inflation inflation hawks have been
telling scary stories about the
impending inflation ever since the
federal reserve slash interest rates to
nearly zero during the financial crisis
of 2008 2000. that's a message that much
of the media has been happy to spread
epitomized by an odd segment about
rising food prices that cnn ran last
week that segment was supposed to show
in the words of a much mock tweet
promoting it how badly inflation is
hitting the middle class but instead of
looking at a typical size middle class
american family it focuses at texas on a
texas family with nine kids on one that
buys 12 gallons of milk a week in the
process that the segments suck them to
succumb to anyways they go into this
whole thing the increase in food and gas
prices that we've seen over the past
eight months is real and meaningful
inflation hawks have been telling scary
stories and impending inflation over
ever since
forever for once they're not making
things up inflation is now running a
little more than five percent driving
largely by energy prices so they
completely changed the article from what
it was before okay because they realized
people were saying what the hell are you
talking about in regards to inflation so
here's the point
the reality of it is people are sitting
on the sidelines today
when they wake up they watch three
different channels for news what are the
three channels they go to for cnn you
got fox cnn and msnbc okay maybe they go
to cbs maybe they go to nbc maybe go to
abc maybe they go with some of this
stuff this is gaslighting at the highest
level to convince people listen this is
normal it's supposed to happen no this
is a byproduct of you constantly
printing money and eventually shit's
going to hit the fan historically we've
never had interest rates as low as we've
had for 13 straight years you can't do
this and fake it for this long
eventually you have to get it back up to
normal when they do maybe this is why
buffett's sitting on that much cash yeah
i don't know maybe buff is in there
saying
hey but my my thing is when you're
looking at dollar any time the
government and the fed's printing
you definitely don't stay cash that's
the caveat look like you know one of the
biggest fears with baseball cards the
following thing here's what baseball
card collectors will say they'll say
things like
like let's just say the wayne gretzky
psa 10 card right the guy who sold me to
wayne gretzky psa 10 card when he bought
it there was only one wayne gretzky psa
10 card so watch this when he bought it
there was only one a year after he owned
it another gretzky psa the opic got
graded psa 10. so in his mind he says
this car is no longer worth 540. it's
now worth 300 thousand dollars yeah his
worry was because there's now two psa
tents so he sold me the card anyways i
ended up selling the car for a couple
million dollars but the point is the the
sporting card market fears
another card getting graded high the
value goes lower yeah suddenly it's
divided by more cards but but the point
is the more they're printing the more
they're printing
you you supply yeah so so it's kind of
confusing what buffett is doing there's
a bit of it that's uh confusing but
we'll see what's going to happen with
this he's not where's buffett on your
list of people you would want to
interview is he in the top ten
i think the very rarely do you find a
guy
that's that smart
that brilliant
that much of a genius who's a comedian
very rarely do you find people like that
he's that fascinating to be that smart
and that funny yeah and that charismatic
and that great of a salesperson you have
to realize
those like look at jeff bezos how funny
is he not at all how charming is he not
too much how charismatic is he not
character to an extent within what his
vision but he's uh outside of that
you're just trying to be nice to the guy
there's nothing about him
nothing about him that's charismatic
right
name me a person that that that much of
a genius who's a great salesperson who's
charismatic
who's tough who makes people laugh i
think the only two people i would put in
that category is him and musk
it's very random to find people like
that
zuck's not in that category um these
guys are anomalies
what's my guy at uh salesforce what's
his name benny hoff jack benioff is that
his first name yeah
mark bennett that guy's got some swag to
him i want to say
at buffett's level no no i don't know i
don't know i don't know if you would
call buffett swaggy but he's certainly
oh there's got humor there's no way you
don't give buff at swag you got it
you're giving them some buffett's got
swag man well here's what i'll say about
buffett and this is maybe a lesson to
all the grandparents out there
you asked like what could bring him down
dementia all the time or something like
that
there's something to be said about he's
not retiring he's he's kept going he's
not like he's
75 time to retire he's just keeping it
going keeping it moving keeping the mind
sharp and you know they say that when
you retire and you do nothing that's
when the mind starts to go yeah the guy
is as active as ever and it's not like
he's some physical fitness guru the guy
eats mcdonald's every day for breakfast
he's probably could use a few lose a few
pounds but the brain is so freaking
sharp
that that's probably explains why he's
what i'm saying father time there's
certain games you play that father time
doesn't come challenging think about
sports you have a lifespan yeah
challenging part about anything that has
to do with that but the brain yeah
something with this this is 60 years can
you imagine if
athletes could have a 60 year career
lifespan think about that he is
essentially an athlete that's played for
60 70 years i think the only thing with
brady is like he has
such a good body but also game awareness
that he's been playing so long and he
understands the way things move and
stuff like that which is possibly why
he's he's having such an advantage he is
and to imagine to do that for another 20
years i mean that's crazy yeah well you
know they you we talked about this with
scottie pippen like you need to have a
second act if you're in sports right as
as amazing as your career may go
it's going to be over by age 40 a lot of
times earlier than that
like the oldest is is 40. i mean brady
the fact that he's still doing it at 40.
he says he wants to go to 50 by the way
we'll see about that but the point is
i think warren buffett made 90 of his
money after age 60. something ridiculous
like that
so
whether you use the athlete analogy if
you're an athlete um it's important to
reinvent yourself but if you're going to
be in the investment world in the
business world there's no end in sight a
guy reads four hours a day this is not
an arrogant cocky billionaire you're
talking about a guy that's
so humble so like i'm always wanting to
learn and get better this is not a
schlep this is the goat you're talking
about the goat there's only one goat in
the space he's it today okay a lot of
people that want to be the greatest one
of the best the current they're good for
a decade they're good for two decades
i've never heard anybody have a number
one hit in music seven decades yeah i've
never heard anybody the only thing is
when you got the three names right you
got sting you got ray charles and one
other that had a number one hit in four
different decades i think it's only two
or three names that had a number one hit
in four different decades staying great
charles and one other name gary kasparov
gary cass probably that's why they're
251 months in a row that's insane 250
something months that's in that category
but you're not probably not talking
about bands
it doesn't matter but they may be in
that category but the point is to do it
seven decades yeah it's insane that's
insane so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]